now the foreign office has confirmed
that the uk is sending war crimes
experts to help the authorities in
ukraine with investigations into
atrocities allegedly carried out but
denied by russia and i'm joined now from
kiev by iriana
venektova the prosecutor general of
ukraine and it's very kind of you to be
with us uh this evening
what kind of war crimes have you
identified
good afternoon dear friends thank you
very much that you are having me
actually if we take the wrong statute
article 8 about war crimes we can find
in ukraine almost everything
unfortunately healing of civilians no
torturing sorry
ukrainian language in the mind torturing
then bombing and attacking civilian
object uh sexual crimes and other other
and others now we have near 9 000 cases
only about war crimes
truly truly awful and you've named
russian soldiers haven't you allegedly
involved in human rights abuses mainly
in the town of butcher how have you
managed to identify these men
actually we have victims who are alive
after torturing these 10 soldiers of
russian federation we started to
prosecute them or for
their loopers and they people
they tortured ukrainian civilians and
people whom they tortured we have
several victims who
alive after their torturing that's why
we have
enough evidence to start prosecuting
them because
we have interrogation of
witnesses of victims and other evidence
which help us to be successful in the
court
so you've identified 10 russian soldiers
do you know where they are at the moment
are they still fighting in ukraine do
you believe
actually yes we start
to prosecute and
them in absentees that's why it's uh
possible three variants were they or
they are still
here in on the territory of our
country and still fighting or they are
now dead or maybe they on the territory
of russian federation but again we've
started this process and for us it's
very important these 10 soldiers they
are first tenth in butcher but we we
identified are the five
persons uh they are soldiers of russian
federation from other districts of kiev
region
who uh one of them we started to
prosecute him in uh raping
are these in
lover
you mentioned that you have been getting
help from the victims
and from those who had to witness uh
what allegedly happened and and that
must be very difficult but the public's
help is is crucial isn't it here
uh that's true from first days of war we
have common uh hub for all law
enforcement bodies in ukraine and other
state institutions
institutions war crimes.gov dot uae and
now we have more than 12 000 statements
from ordinary people journalists angels
about
such war crimes with video with
photo fixations with other data so which
we try to save and of course so
this cooperation with civil society is
absolutely necessary in such cases
twelve thousand statements in such a
short time that really is incredible now
moscow of course denies any human rights
abuses and russian state tv has even
suggested that footage of dead civilians
in butcher was staged by the ukrainian
authorities what do you say to those
sort of accusations by moscow
it's ordinary or moscow propaganda
i think that the citizens maybe still
think that here is not war but special
operation and of course i'm um
actually i was interested about the
absolutely psychology of russian
citizens it's very strange
they they are so
uneducated and don't understand the
narratives of all these political
propaganda from kremlin all these
speeches about dinosaications about
fakes about other very
strange things which we hear in 21st
century it is propaganda from maybe 12th
century 13th century but not in modern
time that's why of course we will hear
from russian federation some strange
things but yesterday all who always saw
then we had here in kiev five
missiles when he were very
honored persons uh the head of united
nations and the prime ministery
of
the state it's very strange
don't don't you mind
uh and uh and you're very grateful
presumably for the international help we
know the british are now going to poland
to help with the uh the forensics behind
trying to identify uh not only the
victims but also the perpetrators of
these alleged abuses as well irina
benedictova prosecutor general of
ukraine we really appreciate your time
this evening thank you very much for
speaking to us on sky news